all right we are live on the youtube i'm
dave rubin
and welcome to another reuben report
friday roundtable extravaganza
today we're going to be talking big tech
censorship lawsuits
joe biden finally we finally got a
democrat to say something against the c
word and la county has just reinstated
its mask mandate i'm so thrilled i can't
even put it into words
joining me today are a senior fellow at
the claremont
institute which just had a big hit piece
written on it david reboy
uh political commentator and twitter
band recipient rogan o'hanley
and lawyer at the dillon law group ron
coleman
fellas welcome to the reuben report
thanks david great to be
on dave all right i think you guys are
basically
as perfect a trio as possible for me to
have on right now because there is so
much going on in the censorship
world it's actually completely insane so
we're going to start
uh with two videos from white house
press secretary jenn saki and i've been
showing videos of her for the last
couple weeks this woman
cannot say a true statement like it's
it's actually impossible
for her to say anything even close to
true
and now she's going all in they're
basically admitting that the
administration
coordinates with facebook at least and
probably some of the other big tech
companies
to censor our legal speech so here
is clip one so about i think this was a
question asked before
there's about 12 people who are
producing 65 percent of anti-vaccine
misinformation
on social media platforms all of them
remain active on facebook
despite some even being banned on other
platforms including facebook
ones that facebook owns third it's
important to take faster action against
harmful posts as you all know
information travels quite quickly on
social media platforms
sometimes it's not accurate and facebook
needs to move more quickly to remove
harmful violative posts posts that will
be within their policies for removal
often remain up for days
that's too long the information spreads
too quickly finally
we have proposed they promote quality
information sources in their feed
algorithm facebook has repeatedly shown
that they have the leverage to promote
quality information we've seen them
effectively
do this in their algorithm over low
quality information and
they've chosen not to use it in this
case and that's certainly
an area that would have an impact so
these are certainly the proposals
we engage with them regularly and they
certainly understand what our asks are
okay before i do anything else there ron
i think your microphone might be doing a
little something crazy there so we're
getting some background information
we're getting a little background sound
so try not to move it that much i think
that might be you
but we shall see all right there's a lot
that she said there i mean in essence
the administration is now flagging posts
for facebook so that means the
government is telling a
you know quote unquote private entity
what to do related to speech
and they're warning us about these 12
people that are spreading misinformation
about vaccines
i mean i think even if it is
misinformation you're allowed to speak
freely in america at least that's what i
thought
rogan is the twitter band guy i'll let
you
chime in here first what is going on
between the government
and big tech i mean we have cuba here at
home
you know yesterday was the first time we
heard the biden administration actually
openly
uh denounced communism yet in the other
hand
they're promoting communist china
censorship
practices now on the biggest social
media platform in the world i think
that these people should be reminded
she's not a uh you know soccer mom
she's not on a political campaign she is
the voice of the white house
the executive branch our federal
government our first amendment
was put in place specifically to stop
this type of censorship practice and
they seem to they don't even mention it
they don't even mention
this it's going to balance their
interest against it all they want to do
is censor any dissenting voices against
this administration
ron i'm not a lawyer you are a lawyer
but this seems like the outsourcing of
tyranny basically the administration
says
oh we know that we can't ourselves just
completely take away the first amendment
but we can tell big tech companies what
to do i mean she's literally saying we
are flagging
for them that that word for implies they
are working together
to censor speech yeah it's really
problematic and it strikes me
as a purposeful
rolling out of the position that the
government's going to take here i don't
think
i think whether it's as a result of the
lawsuit that we filed on behalf of rogan
against california and a number of other
entities including twitter
or whether it's unrelated which is
possible
it seems that the that the federal
government in other words
the democratic party i don't think
there's just much of a difference at
this point
have made a decision that they're going
to fight and be prepared to die on this
hill
which they can't do the constitution
does not allow you to outsource
censorship anything the government the
government cannot do
the government can't hire someone else
to do either hire or influence or
pressure
or work with which by the way this is
completely consistent you guys may
remember
the hearing about a year ago where aoc
was basically trying to pressure mark
zuckerberg
into centering things on facebook and
and he said you know
we can't do that if you pressure us to
do that that's a first amendment issue i
mean i don't have that many great things
to say about zuckerberg but in that case
he was right
uh reboy i know you've been tracking
this stuff forever i mean i assume none
of this
surprises you but are you at least are
you somewhat surprised that there's
basically
no pushback almost anywhere i mean yeah
a bunch of us on
youtube but like that's pretty much it
right i mean i think this is uh
basically an illegitimate theory um
this is clearly where they have been
going for the last several decades
from you know mark marcusa until now i
mean when i grew up i tell the story a
lot
i think i was in fourth or fifth grade
when we when we talked about the skokie
nazis
and i was in a jewish school and the
moral of the story was that that
that that our liberty was more important
than any
particular security we may feel um
and and and the right of people to speak
or to assemble
under the first amendment is is you know
is paramount
and uh we spent 20 years throughout the
uh the war on terror having this
argument in one way or another
and it seems like as soon as the
democrats got into power
as soon as they got the um
you know as soon as they made the long
march through the institutions
uh you know this one including the the
political institutions but also the
corporate institutions
with regards to big tech then you know
it's it's game on in order to censor
speech that
um that that they don't like and um
obviously this is it should be
incredibly troubling to
you know not only your listeners but but
really to every american
um this is your birthright and um and
it's
uh and it's it's disappearing really
really fast and
the other thing is it puts a lie to a
lot of the folks who are saying oh no
you know start your own x y and z start
your own
you know massive uh social media uh
conglomerate with millions of uh you
know of users and
and and such um they're demanding it all
be shut down and it's really only a
matter of time
until we get to the point where this is
going to be
a you know a real fight out in the open
um
you know the government trying to shut
down every single outlet for example
they're going to go after locals they're
going to go after
um they're really going to go after
everybody because as ron said this is
um they're they're
they're spelling out the future
priorities of um
you know of the uh of the kind of
progressive state
right and of course the irony is that if
they were going after misinformation if
that's really what they were going for
you'd have to ban
every cnn correspondent every msnbc
correspondent
uh you know brett kavanaugh justin like
all of these hoaxes
russia ukraine etc etc covington kids
so yeah you're going to ban all those
people i don't think that's exactly what
they're doing but
reboy you gave me a great segue to this
other clip that we found literally two
minutes before we started
this is sake this morning and now it's
not just that if you're banned from one
thing maybe you have a chance on some of
the others
they're pushing for the whole damn thing
let's take a look providing
for for facebook or other platforms to
measure and publicly share the impact of
misinformation on their platform
and the audience it's reaching also with
the public
with all of you to create robust
enforcement strategies that bridge their
properties and provide transparency
about rules you shouldn't
be banned from one platform and not
others
if you affor providing misinformation
man she's evil i i have no other way to
describe it at this point she is evil
you shouldn't be banned from one
platform and not
others well first off i thought they
were private companies but i guess we're
learning
that they're not uh rogan you were
banned from uh twitter so first off you
want to explain a little bit of what
your lawsuit is which ron is your lawyer
i should have mentioned that up top
do you want to explain that and then and
then are you anywhere else at the moment
because under saki's rules
uh you'd be persona non grata
yeah i mean per sakes uh protocol
i should be banned off all platforms uh
after being uh you know uh uh
malevolently banned on twitter you know
they're compounding the problem here so
i am on
almost every platform i can think of i
have over three million followers
thankfully across these other platforms
but i had almost half a million on
twitter i was rising very quickly and
you know i had the audacity to question
election irregularities
after the election had taken place i am
a licensed lawyer in the state of
california
i also have common sense and when i read
sworn affidavits hundreds of them when i
see dead voters voting in michigan when
i
uh uh you know look at these videos of
pulling you know
pallets of uh ballots under under from
tables when
republican observers have been kicked
out i ask questions and i say hey we
should probably look at this further no
different than
you know what stacey abrams did in the
2018 gubernatorial race and what
recently mayor de blasio did with the
you know
car accident of a democrat primary where
they had 135
000 test votes accidentally mixed in so
um i i asked for the same things i said
we should audit california elections
and my tweets started to get censored on
election stuff
uh you know where it says you cannot be
retweeted or commented due to risk of
violence
um so asking for an audit was a risk of
violence in their minds and
judicial watch actually uncovered uh
thousands of emails from the secretary
of state
to twitter where they specifically cited
multiple social media influencers
including myself in that specific tweet
in california and asked them to censor
it
twitter of course complied and obliged
them and uh you know i
six weeks or so later was ultimately
banned for
you guessed it election integrity issues
so
uh you know we we in my opinion have
them dead to rights here with the
evidence this is a clear
joint state actor situation where
twitter goes from a private company
to an extension of the of the state
government
at that time so i think discovery will
be a very
interesting process to see what else was
going on behind the scenes
right maybe you are one of the 12 people
that saki
is worried about that would be that
would be quite an honor ron
at a legal level uh when she's saying
when saki's saying we flag them for
facebook
what's the process in discovery
basically that you have to do as a
lawyer to prove oh yes
it's not that they're just sending them
and saying hey do what you want but in
essence that
is coercion in and of itself well
we have a lot less to do now than we had
to do a week ago
because of the statements that she just
made those are admissions
there couldn't be and you'll notice that
she was reading a very
carefully prepared statement and you
this reinforces my view that it that an
executive decision
was made by the leaders of the united
states government whoever those people
happened to be
to uh to as i said before to roll this
out
the words were chosen and wordsworth
very very carefully
so we have to do a lot less but what we
want to do
is get a hold of as many emails as we're
not or i mean
with the work that's already been done
by judicial watch
which essentially does what journalists
used to do uh we've got
so much right now the only thing that i
think that that we would need to do
is to just make sure that you know
things were
even hotter smoking guns were not
withheld from the from the fourier
requests
and take some depositions uh they're
admitting
what we're accusing them of and
they're also setting up future
likely damage constitutional damage
which is
considered to be irreparable harm by
virtue of essentially
admitting that they want to
coordinate the united states
government's policy and enforcement
actions
with the program of an organization a
coalition of organizations called
change the terms which you can find to
change the terms dot org
it's a rogues gallery of left-wing
anti-speech
activists and they're precisely trying
to
set up a situation where as she's said
if you are
banned on one social media platform
you're banned on all social media
platforms in the case of someone like
rogan who makes his living
entirely from social media
right now um destroy a person
yeah guys you know we're gonna actually
dump the second story biden said
communism okay
it's a miracle a democrat actually said
the word communism because we
obviously got to keep going with this um
david do you think that what ron just
said there that
they're sort of admitting it now right
it's a carefully worded statement where
she said
four but in a weird way this reminds me
of my show last week i had uh author
walter kern on and we were talking about
tucker in the nsa
and what his point was is they want you
to know that they're spying on you they
want you to know that they're in cahoots
with facebook because then they just put
it all out in your face and then
they just make you more fearful like
that that we're at that stage of
america basically right
yeah i i think walter is a very smart
guy
um in addition to being a a great writer
and um and yeah i mean i think that's
absolutely true
uh it's uh you know we're we've we've
got a situation where
um you know maybe the the silver lining
here is that uh
we can hate them you know maybe a
fraction as much as they seem to hate us
right i i don't know that we're going to
do anything about it although some of us
are
actually everyone in these boxes is
doing doing a little bit of something
rogan what would you want to happen with
your lawsuit i mean is the is the goal
of the lawsuit they just let you back on
twitter or
or should we just try to destroy these
companies i mean even right now after
you said what you said a few moments ago
about the election
like technically i'm pretty sure
youtube's allowed to blow up my channel
for that just because you
expressed your your free sentiment right
there
well i expressed sentiments that are
being validated across the country with
the democratic process at the state
level we're seeing it in arizona we're
seeing it in
georgia and i you know am aware of
youtube's strict guidelines trying very
much to
play in them while also just reporting
on the news that is actually occurring
in the world
um so you know i i've told people people
have asked me
they're like oh how much money are you
gonna get you know what
what would you take a settlement and i
tell them listen they could come to me
tomorrow
six months from now a year from now with
uh you know a written offer
20 million dollars in your pocket will
give you your twitter back this all goes
away and i would say hell no
we're taking this all the way to what i
hope is the supreme court
and we'll have o'hanley v padilla in law
school textbooks one day and it will be
the case that gives us at least partial
first amendment rights on
social media to protect all americans
now and forever in the future because
uh this is a massive problem
unfortunately we have spineless gop
uh you know rhinos dominating congress
and they have refused
refused even as the sitting president of
the united states
was banned from the platform they still
have refused to make it the number one
priority legislative issue uh we're
starting to get some movement now but in
my opinion this is the greatest civil
rights battle of our time
and we're going to fight it all the way
to the top and frankly i think if we get
to the supreme court it'll be at least a
seven
two eight one maybe even nine zero
decision
what is it what does it say about uh
what does it say about
the state of america such as it is
that uh we're relying on a couple of
justices you know and not even really a
couple of justices but
you know several judges um
you know up and down the line um you
know you before
before it even gets to uh to the supreme
court i mean these are the most
fundamental
you know your ability to speak freely
and to to organize
um is the most fundamental right you
have as an american
you know under the prior regime under
the under the regime of the founders
and historically we'll be hearing from
the aclu by now we've been hearing from
the new york times
and instead what we they're they're
absolutely on board with this
absolutely on board with a new state of
repression which is
which is chilling and it makes you
wonder about every decision they've made
in the past
about what their motivations were so
right to that point
though then okay so if if the lawsuit
keeps moving forward and let's say it
gets all the way to the supreme court
and now we've got them with this smoking
gun statement that as you pointed out
she read
we are flagging them for right like what
what is that
at the end of that what is that like i
mean could it topple the administration
i know that sort of sounds nuts but it's
like
if they found out that biden knew that
they were
actually using the levers of power to
censor speech like
i mean is that completely crazy i think
nothing's crazy at this point
nothing is crazy but i do think that the
political damage does have the potential
to be great i mean just
democrats don't resign the last person
to make that mistake
was joe joe joe
from snl maybe 1974. if you think about
it though it's actually an entirely apt
uh you know uh al franken of course it
was
actually a little bit funnier um
democrats don't resign and and biden
would not have to resign or whoever
is president at the time but i do think
that there would be some
very substantial damage and
well you know what what you'd be looking
here would for here would be not only a
sweeping opinion
but also restraints in other words the
government would be prohibited under an
injunction
from anything from doing anything of
this nature i don't
you know you asked about discovery
before i suppose one of the things we'd
like to know is not only with respect to
to the the immediate banning
of of rogan uh but also
how long has this been going on for the
for for years now we've been hearing
private company private company
you are no longer a private company when
you become an agency of the government
was this something that was just rolled
out for the election that becomes harder
to believe i think what they're
with their what they're doing now is
being more comfortable
with admitting it and with doing it but
if it's
something that's been going on
retroactively for a long time i think
what it has the potential to topple
is not a particular presidential
administration but perhaps
the entire regime of the supranational
state of twitter in the supernatural
state of facebook
all right you know what i said i was
going to drop the second story but it's
actually totally related to all of this
because for a week now with everything
happening in cuba
um you know no democrats basically have
said anything bad about communism if
anything they've subtly endorsed it or
not said anything like aoc and
omar and bernie and the rest of them but
yesterday
biden actually did say the c word and he
kind of condemned it in his sleepy way
take a look at this clip communism is a
fail system
universally fail system and uh i
don't see socialism as a very useful
substitute but that's another story cuba
is a uh unfortunately a failed state and
repressing
uh their citizens
boy inspirational huh that guy could he
wake up a lot of people um all right
let's just do this real quick one one
shot for each you
i mean that he choked that out to me
like there's just nothing behind it and
they are socialists and that's not that
far from communist
david am i over stating this yeah i mean
joe biden has been in political life for
so many decades
and and you know i think his uh his
brain is mush at this point
so sometimes an old script would pot
will pop into his head maybe from 1985
or something like that
and um i've got a feeling that's what
happened here
um i know i'm pretty sure that uh that
they
they uh they denied him a scoop of ice
cream
uh that evening that at the uh at the
white house and you know had him had him
sit alone in a corner
after uh after giving that speech right
when trump has ice cream it's national
news biden gets ice cream and it's like
the greatest thing ever
uh rogan i mean at this point do you
think they are the democrats in effect
are socialists like is there any
meaningful distinction between the
average democrat at this point
and a socialist which of course is only
a stone's throw away from a communist
you know
anytime i call democrats socialists or
communists i always get people in the
comments do you even know what communism
is do you know what socialism is
i think they're just flagrant
authoritarians and the economic system
is really just secondary
to the crushing government power that
they want to enact
on you know these peasants that inhabit
this beautiful country
you know we went from ronald reagan mr
gorbachev tear down this wall right in
his face to uh
hey mr castro could you uh you know
maybe sort of kind of be nicer
socialism isn't so good i mean come on
ron you're not acting as rogan's lawyer
in this capacity are they socialists
oh i think you're muted ron
you see what they did they're trying to
silence me
they're not socialists they are first of
all depends on who we mean by they
the democrats who are in charge of the
democratic party are not socialists
they're not interested in the
redistribution of wealth
they have a great deal of that wealth
they're not interested in
the change of management or
or ownership of the means of production
they don't none of them has even read
marks
they are crony capitalists what they
are doing is playing to their left-wing
base
an activist and donor base which
you know as being a bolshevik style
party this is the one thing that the
democrats will always have
over the republicans which is that they
have party and message
discipline and the rule among democrats
is
no enemies to the left ever so whatever
it takes
yeah it's actually a great point like
pelosi is not willing to give up her
hundreds of millions of dollars and the
ton of money she made on
uh wall street this week so she's not a
socialist in that regard she's just
messaging to those guys all right we got
one more just for two minutes
i'm sure you guys heard last night i
almost killed somebody because i was
sitting there having
a drink after dinner and then it was
announced that la is going to have a
mask mandate i just want to be very
clear
i am not wearing a mask anymore period
these people are all frauds and
ridiculous buffoons
gavin newsom spent fifteen thousand
dollars at french laundry the at the
height of this thing during lockdowns
without a mask and i don't know what are
they gonna arrest me if i walk into a
store
as a young healthy person uh and try to
buy something i mean it's just
completely ridiculous there's no science
behind it that's my thoughts
um rogan what do you think mask mandates
back in la
you're in florida so you're all right
yeah i mean we we've been
uh mask free for a long time i was
unfortunately kicked out of our recent
cpac event
uh that we hosted in florida in february
because uh you know it was in a blue
county
orange county uh you know orlando which
is heavily blue
and you know governor ron de santos got
rid of the statewide mask mandate i
lived in an area where it wasn't
strongly enforced and
i went to that cpac conference and i
said listen this is florida we have to
set the example we're not masked drones
i got kicked out um not by cpac by high
security
but uh you know it it's such a farce i i
don't know how they keep playing this
game
uh when you see how open florida is we
have concerts with 60 000 people
and no spike in cases so uh you know and
again
either the vaccine works or it doesn't
and if they're pushing this vaccine if
so many people especially in bluer areas
have gotten the vaccine
why are they worried about what happens
to anyone else if they don't want the
vaccine that's their choice at this
point well the new meme
is not that it doesn't work but that you
will get a somehow lesser degree of
covid especially related to the delta
variant
that's what they're telling us uh david
has this all just taught you something
about human nature that perhaps we all
knew but we were afraid to admit
yeah we we love um
we love to control others or let's say
there are some of us who love to control
others
and um and it doesn't even really matter
what uh what the the the criteria is or
or what anyone is saying
it's just uh it's it's just very simple
i mean you know the answer
my answer here is just move to florida i
mean at the end of the day i'm not
going to worry i'm working on it down
there you know
you know give me give me some time here
we move the company one thing i know
it's not easy i know it's not easy but
but this is
you know these are the these are the the
steps that have to be made you know not
everybody can
can you know just stand up on a dime and
say okay i'm leaving but
uh but everyone can begin that
conversation
at least in their in their minds and and
with their with their families and
figure out i want to be where i'm
surrounded by people who don't hate me
who don't want to um you know make me a
prisoner of these absurd mask mandates
and and you know
it's it's just it's just better here in
every way and you know what this is also
having a a
a salutary effect in the sense that
there are a lot of folks millions of
americans who didn't give a damn about
politics before
and they didn't understand how it could
affect their lives
and now they can and they see that
these decisions made by anusam
um versus similar decisions made by a
desantis
are worlds apart and they really do
affect their lives and this is why this
stuff
means something that's why it's
important to take part
in this process by the way i will never
say anything nice about gavin newsom and
i think he
is christian bale from american psycho
but i have a feeling he's against the la
mask thing because this has to work
against him in the recall right but ron
now as the lawyer i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you finish up here and i'm
gonna put you on the spot
can you give me some legal advice if i
walk into my supermarket without a mask
and they stop me and i say you know just
an employee or a security guard or
something and says
put on your mask and i say well actually
this is against cdc guidelines it's
against california
state guidelines i'm young and healthy
and i'm just
going to walk in and buy a box of
frosted flakes i won't cough on anybody
or kill grandma
what what legal trouble could i be in at
that point like what
these mandates what legal heft do they
have
they have as much legal heft as the
supermarket in your example wants to
give them
so if you if they're going to maintain a
rule because they're going to maybe get
pressured by
the local government or because they're
run by
you know woke people or whatever the
case may be
you might have to do like david reboy
and find another place to shop
because if that that is a private
company
right so you don't have you don't have a
legal right to ignore the
the mask mandate in a private
environment
uh if they want to rescue on the street
if they made an outdoor mandate
then we can talk but you know we've
we've taken you know we've pushed back
on california pretty pretty heavily and
they're paying a lot of legal fees to a
lot of law firms including ours on the
on
covid related uh power grabs but
you're gonna have to choose a better
supermarket yeah ironically because of
our ridiculous progressive d.a here in
los
angeles george gascon who was the d.a in
san francisco and ruined that city
they don't arrest you right now or they
won't charge you with trespassing or
resisting arrest
so you can go you can go to the
supermarket and shoplift
but you can't go to the supermarket and
breathe
that's a perfect ending guys uh i thank
you for joining me on this friday have a
good weekend and i'll of course have you
guys back for sure and
unfortunately this stuff just ain't
going anywhere and i'm just going to
finish up solo for a minute or two
uh so i thank rogan david and ron
and for you guys man this mask thing
i mean i i really last night i i almost
had like a conniption
my brain almost exploded like it's all
nonsense it's all bs look i am not
sitting here as a representative of the
cdc i am not
sitting here as a scientist i am sitting
here as someone with a little bit
of common sense and i got to tell you in
the last three weeks
in la as things opened up there really
was a feeling
like things are getting better it's
going to be okay i've said from beat one
like when
when people ask me when david reboy asks
me you know what are you doing there
look
what are you still doing in california
in essence um i've said from day one i
wanted to stay and fight that was my
plan with michael knowles at the
beginning of lockdown then of course
daley wire
moved to tennessee and knowles went with
them um but i've
i've also been saying that i want to
stay through this recall
larry elder just got in larry elder i
hold uh
like in the highest possible place in
terms of like the political
pundit thinker fighter class okay
he's got the right ideas born in la he's
he's ready to fight i'm gonna have him
here in studio
on monday and we will talk about this i
i hope he has a chance i will promote in
any possible way
but if we imagine if we could break
through like imagine if gavin newsom
loses the recall and larry elder became
the governor like
it's possible maybe we can start
reversing some of this stuff
and and when i say reversing some of
this stuff it's not just about lockdowns
it's about what we spent the first 25
minutes of the show talking about
which is all of the censorship stuff too
like we now have
an administration that is working with
big tech to silence us
we have state governments in blue states
that are actively trying to go
anti-science what
what la is doing is against the cdc and
we're told that
the cdc is science right palpatine i am
the senate
um so we've got our work cut out for us
that seems to be the uh the statement
that i make at every
at the end of every show uh but i'm glad
to be in the fight with you guys
and one way or another we're gonna be
all right like i really just
i believe that and we just need more of
you guys to keep fighting so i thank you
guys
for watching if you want to play along
over the weekend and look oh i guess my
youtube channel might have just got
blown up or could be there could be a
meeting right now
susan at youtube could be having a
meeting you know rogan said something a
few minutes ago he's a free man and
reuben let him on
join us reubenreport.locals.com we don't
coordinate
with the government and i don't care
what you say and if you break the law
you got a bigger problem than dave rubin
all right have a great weekend everybody